everyone
flight council mr marisol the jury sent
out a note about 10 minutes ago that
they have in fact reached a verdict in
this matter
so we're going to bring the jurors in in
a moment before we do i understand it
was an emotional case so
for those interested in the courtroom um
please don't outcries i understand there
may be some emotion here
regardless of what the verdict is so
please respect the jury when they're in
the courtroom
and no outcries no comments
all right we'll bring the jurors in now
thank you any alternatives
ready
all right be seated everyone
all right mr foreman please rise please
mr foreman has the jury agreed upon a
verdict in this case
is that verdict unanimous
it is with regard to count one attempted
murder of lauren canaract what is your
verdict not guilty by reason of insanity
with regard to count two attempted
murder
of
robert goodwin what is your verdict sir
with regard to count two the lesser
included offense of aggravated assault
upon
robert goodwin what is your verdict
on count three possession of a weapon
for an unlawful purpose to use against
the person of lawrence counteract what
is your verdict not guilty by reason of
insanity
and with regard to count for possession
of a weapon for an unlawful purpose
what is your verdict
right now you may be seeing it mr for me
thank you
by members of the jury you have heard
the verdict as reported by your fourth
person
and i will now have a polling of each of
you individually
and the verdict as read by your foreman
is as follows
on count one attempted murder
not guilty by reason of insanity
on count two attempted murder not guilty
on the lesser included offense
aggravated assault not guilty
on count three possession of a weapon
for an unlawful purpose with regard to
lauren canorack not guilty by reason of
insanity
and finally on count four possession of
a weapon foreign a lawful purpose
regarding
robert goodwin not guilty
if this is your verdict as i go around
i'll call each juror's number and if
that's your verdict simply say yes if
it's not your verdict just indicate no
all right all right beginning uh with
juror number one is that your verdict
yes
and juror number three is that your
verdict yes
jury number four yes
you're number five yeah
you're number six yes
and juror number eight yeah
juror number ten
yes
uh juror number eleven yes
and you're number twelve yes
and you're on number thirteen yes sir
number 14 yes and finally juror number
16. yes
very good
um and mr foreman there was a spot on
the verdict form for your signature and
the date did you sign and date the
verdict for i did
can you hand that to one of my court
officers please they'll bring it up that
will be
kept by the court
in our court file for future reference
thank you
so
all right i did review the verdict sheet
it is uh marked as the foreman announced
it
and it is signed invaded by the fourth
person so that will be kept by the court
thank you
all right very good uh ladies and
gentlemen the jury
the function you have performed is one
of the most important civic duties which
you will ever be called upon to fulfill
if you recall i said that at the very
beginning of the case when we were
picking a jury i thought next to
military service
serving as a juror
in a case is
one of the most or
the most important civic duty he will be
called upon to fulfill and with the
return of the verdict in this case your
service as yours in this case is
complete
upon your discharge you are not required
except upon order of this court to
discuss your deliberations or verdict
with anyone
additionally no attorney or party or
person acting for them is permitted
under the rules of court to examine or
question you about this matter or your
role in its outcome
if any of these persons approaches you
and attempts to interview you please
notify me or my staff immediately
you may also be
contacted by others including members of
the media
i'm sure it's no surprise to you that
this case given the cameras in the
courtroom has received
attention from the media
and there uh is media present now uh in
the courtroom
there's also a news magazine i'm sure
some of you have heard of it 48 hours
that has been recording this trial not
you
um but the proceedings the jurors are
not shown but they have been reporting
the trial for
future broadcast sometime in the fall
they have asked that my court staff
provide you each with a letter by their
producer
they may wish to speak to you they
cannot approach you individually but
they'll my staff will give you a letter
with the name of the producer on the
phone number if you wish to speak to her
you can contact her you can throw the
letter in the trash on your way out if
you want it's completely up to you
however
if you agree to be interviewed you may
discuss whatever you want in whatever
manner you deem appropriate however
please keep in mind the key to your
function as jurors has been the free
discussion among yourselves during your
deliberations and the privacy of those
deliberations is essential to the
continuation of the fair administration
of justice
all jurors have the
prerogative to keep confidential their
communications with their fellow jurors
during deliberations
it is in the public interest that there
be
the utmost freedom of discussion in the
jury room
and that each juror be committed to
express their views without concern for
public reaction
under no circumstances
should you make any statement that you
would not be willing to repeat under
oath
in open court in the presence of your
fellow jurors
all right with that ladies and gentlemen
you will be dismissed by the court i i
do want to thank you personally for the
service you have provided in this case
it was a long case it was an important
case
and you have all sir very admirable
being you're all as jurors i do know
that
i never had an issue with a juror coming
late to court
they were here ready to go most of the
time by shortly after 8 30 in the
morning so i appreciate that very much
thank you all for your service you are
now discharged you may go next door sure
you have belongings there you can get
your belongings and leave everyone is
going to stay in a courtroom until you
have left the floor as well thank you
very much enjoy your weekend
no you'd have to stay out
happy seating everyone
my counsel in light of the verdict
count one is not guilty by reason of
insanity
count three is not guilty by reason of
insanity there was an equator on counts
two and four
because of that the defendant mr
barristone will now be civilly committed
i will enter an order today
or have him uh having him
committed to the custody or the
commissioner of the department of health
pursuant to njsa2c4-8
[Music]
and pending medical clearance for
admission
the professional staff
at the ancline forensic center
will make a determination as required
pursuant to 2c
colon 4-8-a
with regard to
the present
whether
condition
defendant poses a danger to himself or
others in the community
whether the defendant requires
hospitalization
or may be released to the community
under certain conditions
well that examination
i believe requires 30 days
to bear with me and i'll pick a date
when we can have our first scroll
hearing if we go into the matter
you do it on um
assuming the ant client gets the report
done
i'll schedule it for
may 17th
we both uh everyone available that day
that's your honor
yes sir
just that will be in person
that's an in-person proceeding
it'll be at nine o'clock in the morning
and because of the nature of the
preceding council it is a closed
proceeding
it's not a murder case i agree with that
it was a murder case it would be open to
the public but because it's not a murder
case it is a closed proceeding
all right very good i'll enter the order
we'll have it filed today in light of
the verdict
copies will be posted on the e-course
for council
and um mr barristone will be transported
down to the ant client center once the
order is filed
all right
very good thank you all
um
okay
you